it's not just you your daily coffee
ritual
is getting more expensive if you walk
into an american cafe right now
your average coffee drink is going to
run you around four dollars and fifty
cents
five years ago it would have cost you
just three dollars and 85 cents nearly a
17
rise in prices that's compared to
inflation which has grown around 10
percent during the same period
that rise is driven by a myriad of
economic forces
that help determine the cost of your
morning cup and now
experts say that due to a major crop
loss in 2020
in a matter of months prices could go up
even more
we'll explain
the price of coffee is driven in part by
a complex global supply chain
which shapes a more than 460 billion
dollar market
most coffee beans are produced in brazil
vietnam and colombia
they're then loaded on ships like these
and then transported around the world
this well-oiled system moves the beans
to importing countries
like the us where they're then sold to
coffee traders who sell them to
roasteries
the roasted coffee is then sold to
distributors such as grocery stores and
cafes
max cope steak is a coffee futures
broker the trade operates on paper thin
margins is extremely competitive
business now
things like shipping costs are massive
during the pandemic
the industry has faced a number of
shipping disruptions a shipping
container shortage in southeast asia
has driven up the price of many
commodities including coffee
everything is taking longer to get from
one place to the other
containers are piling up in places where
they
shouldn't be jose cechi is the executive
director of the ico
a leading intergovernmental organization
for coffee
it's not just southeast asia all over
the world
we have problems finding sufficient
containers
so that means that freight rates tend to
rise
and increase prices coffee exports are
also affected by storms
in nicaragua and honduras communities
were devastated by hurricanes last year
they caused a lot of damage to
infrastructure washed out
bridges landslides that block roads
the destroyed roads blocked trade routes
and this meant the supply being imported
into countries like the us
was diminished the concern over a lack
of supply
helped drive up the price of coffee
futures and experts say this could
continue
as temperature increases this affects
the viability of growing coffee
especially arabica coffee robusta as its
name
indicates is robust is strong and
is harder to be affected by
climatic phenomena it's very resistant
but
arabica coffee is more delicate
it grows within quite a narrow
temperature range over the past year the
world's largest coffee producer
brazil faced a drought that devastated
crops
the international coffee organization
says that around 30
of the country's arabica crop may have
been lost
this year's coffee yields will also be
lower because brazil is at an off-cycle
harvest
which happens every other year the off
cycle is small
and we know that anyway but this year is
extra small and this has got people
really spooked
because all of a sudden everyone's like
hang on we need this huge country
because
we become so reliant on you merrick
spectron estimates that the global
coffee market will produce millions
fewer bags than the previous crop year
you can see these factors are pushing up
the price of coffee futures
but overall the effects of the drought
haven't yet been felt in your local cafe
or grocery store
with weather becoming more extreme
around the world due to climate change
experts say risk to coffee production
will continue as
temperatures increase you would expect
to find that
areas that currently produce arabica
will become too hot and we have to think
about ways to
mitigate this whether by different
farming techniques or whether and this
is a more difficult process migrating
production
and as volatile weather increasingly
leads to fluctuations in the supply of
coffee
demand tends to stay pretty steady this
is because coffee is relatively
inelastic
meaning that even when the economy
fluctuates people keep buying beans
it doesn't change much if prices go
up or down let me try and explain this
in
simple terms if prices
double in your supermarket next week
you are likely to change your habits
to some extent you
will maybe switch over to a cheaper
brand you may not
drink as much coffee outside the home
where it is more expensive but it's
unlikely you'll stop drinking coffee
altogether
when the pandemic took hold in march
2020 people were forced to stay home
demand for out-of-home coffee plunged
but demand for in-home coffee rose
making up some of the difference in
consumption and as the pandemic
continued
another pressure on coffee pricing was
playing out in global currencies
coffee future prices are tied to the us
dollar and brazilian real
the dollar is a global safe haven in
times of economic trouble
so during the pandemic coffee farmers
were incentivized to take advantage of
the strong exchange rate
and sell off their beans the result less
stored coffee will be available next
harvest
when crop yields are expected to be
unusually low
this is causing an imbalance between the
lower supply of coffee
and the expected rise in demand and this
is why experts say coffee prices are
currently lower than they should be
they say that this expected rise in
prices will affect the entire supply
chain
and in six to nine months it could drive
up the price of your morning cup
even more